Ireland is a country and a nation formed by migration.
People coming here from other parts of the world
and people from Ireland
going to all sorts of other parts of the world.
And by enlarge, um,
migration has been good for Ireland.
Wouldn't be able to run our public services, uh.
Our restaurants or shops
if it wasn't for migrant workers. Uh.
And certainly the big companies that are here
that pay all the taxes
that pay for the housing
and the pensions and social welfare
wouldn't be here
if we weren't open to talent from all over the world.
Uh, so I think that's the most important thing
and we shouldn't be afraid to say that
and say it every time this topic comes up.
But I do want to reassure people
that migration in Ireland is rules based.
I hear absolute myths
about us somehow having an open borders policy
or rolling at the red carpet and
welcoming people to come here regularly.
That is just not the case.
We have a rule space system
and it's rules that we apply.
And I think we need to
let people know a bit more about what the rules are
and then reassure them that those rules uh.
Are being um.
Are being enforced. Um.
And that's uh.
A big part of what we have to do, uh.
Particularly in 2024.